situations we are examining men's bodies
that's - 65 - 65 all your stories start
with life so I'm in my underwear with
this other guy or this other guy's ass
I'm gay man almost I'm on there i wearin
establish that I'm kinda I'm a little
gay you're appreciative of it I get it
yeah I want you on though one of the
reasons was I was doing Bobby's podcast
and I didn't know he cancelled
yeah he told me he was supposed to come
to my podcast and he's like I'm doing
his podcast first he's gonna do his
podcast he's gonna come over after and
then on on [ __ ] air on his podcast he
calls me he called he face I'm not live
on there but originally he's like I just
don't feel like going yeah he calls you
and says his who's I who died and then
he thought you'd give him [ __ ]
but Eric he's such a good dude goes damn
I'm sorry about that man yeah hey do you
need anything I'm being like that and
Bobby felt way works yeah it feels like
it Bobby lie about his uncle nine no no
whoa glad she died his uncle died 25
years ago so in his mind he's like I
didn't lie have you ever done that if
you ever like used a fake dead relative
to never dad oh my sickness he's a kid a
lot for sickness a kid sick can't make
it tonight you know kid works yeah then
you don't wanna wish some bad luck can't
find a sitter
can't find a sitter or Zinner Dale I
think Larkin live I wouldn't put a piece
of [ __ ] you know I mean how about this
but how did it feel yeah he still came
and did it yeah people asked me to do
that podcast and I'm like no I'm like no
I don't want to what now it becomes a
thing where it's like this like four
things I don't want people to ask me
okay don't ask me to help you move Oh
real friends don't do that go [ __ ]
yourself who are you hi I don't need
pizza I don't need like you know I mean
I don't drink beer like soda whatever
you're gonna offer yeah like I could get
myself here ask me ask me help you move
what can you help me move $55,000
exactly exactly
people go let's say I ask you guys to
help me move the next step is I go pay
for it so why don't you no need just go
[ __ ] pay for okay so I don't want to
answer
you move don't ask me to take you to the
airport okay like uber are you kidding
me [ __ ] okay bro you mind just run me
the airport yeah no yeah I wouldn't do
that to you and I'm right here never I
mean I mean never ever touch my god I've
had to go the airport from here and it
would have been weird emos it would be I
refused so much easier what let's see
this real friends don't ask them no but
I'm thinking of a day when there was no
over like you know say ten years ago
yeah that was the thing where you'd be
like hey it's like no so I don't want
I'm not taking you to the airport okay
that's not even I'm not picking you up
either I don't want the other one is I
don't want to read your script okay
don't give me your script [ __ ] you never
mean like [ __ ] you and your script
because that happens a lot you know no
hey can you check out this like no no
like this is because you know why
because because this is - it I don't
want to read your script I don't want to
go to your play people giving you books
I keep getting books Lee yeah that's
what I'm saying is you don't give me
your paw look don't give me your book
don't give me your place you know I I
don't want to I don't want to yeah I
don't want to read your script and the
other one is like I don't want to go to
your play I don't want to go to your
also come to my come to the movie I
wrote and directed oh that no one is
ever gonna say okay and I'm having a
screening okay over at Johnny Johnny
[ __ ] mesquita and [ __ ] you screenings
of the word hey man I'd rather do I you
know with a copy at the dentist
yeah what a talk after tonight talk to
an if you wouldn't mind being part of
the kid yeah I don't know your script
and then the last one is you know just
getting to the point where you'd be like
I don't want to be on your podcast yeah
it's hard for me to say that because I
have a podcast I asked people to be on
my podcast but that's a reach there's a
certain level of like pocket you're like
Eric Griffin I know but it's like it's
weird because sometimes people you they
hit you up and they're like hey can you
you know I see that it is a commitment
it's a cod keV yeah well having run your
own erdogan so so going to go on like to
go on someone's podcast like that you
don't know the person that you're also
using your energy and like you have your
own show so oh no I need it for you to
say is I've
this yeah can you do my pocket well
where is it well so we do it at we do it
at 4:00 in the van I would rather it's
like till Bobby goes dude it's this
people been asking forever what took so
long with you doom on Mondays Bobby
Mondays at 7 p.m. you know worth calling
you know why I started doing it at home
I started doing it at my place is
because I was going off his comedy I'm
still part off things comedy but they
they're Studios in Burbank and there's
so many people in films as so many
people do it there that like I can't get
a good time
so I'm asking people to come at like 6
o'clock never you know never have 6 p.m.
never I asked him to come do it you know
he was ready he didn't want to drive to
Burbank so much that he was gonna set up
my podcast at my place I'll bring
someone will bring cameras will do this
yeah actually pushed me over the edge
till I do it at home yeah anything to
get out of that yeah of course I want to
do it no no I get it but guys just a
nicer it's a night I also taught we talk
for a living so I talk I do two podcasts
on Monday I do my another right yeah
just a lot then we do this podcast and
Wednesday I got stand-up at night and
I'm on the road so it's like okay I'm
sick myself walking I'm sick of hearing
myself talk I'm a little longer on
someone else's podcast yeah it's a lot I
get it that being said what are you guys
coming no we had a good time to it I
it's called riffing with Griffen Griffen
Griffen check it out
yeah I don't think I have the voice you
know maybe I had the voice of an angel
being face of a calm I didn't know you
could say wow why actually I'm actually
good thing
I have a good voice put your gut into it
like a chimp through 30 times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gif it's a gift
it's a gift